anyway here are some pramas protests in
London because this is the big Saturday
thing they're doing in London
now all right you get it it's a lot of
river to the Sea it's and the 75 year
occup which is ironic because they're in
London and of course if we were to end
the 75 year occupation we would have to
bring back the British Empire I don't
know that any of them want that I don't
know that the average Brit wants it much
less much less the terrorist
sympathizers that are out there doing
that but how long can a
society hold something like this like I
can show you there were plenty of calls
for uh they were talking about how the
Nazis should finish a job like trust me
we went through 50 videos of like the
actual firing of fireworks at police
officers and all all that stuff but you
guys get it the reason I wanted to show
you that one is how long can a society
hold this position that on every weekend
let's say or or twice a week there will
be Mass protests calling for a genocide
of people halfway across the world plus
a certain amount of your own citizens
using all of the freedoms of your nation
so that you can uh basically grow homeg
grow your own Society within a society
like how long does that work if you were
say a a Jewish person living in London
would you want one of those people to be
your dentist would you want one of them
to be your Uber driver do you see how
this might start actually like singing
all of the little pieces that give us
connectivity in a society and again it's
not just about the Jews if you're just
an average British citizen who is proud
of their country who knows what their
history
was